- For some people, Broadway may seem
like it's just for diehard theater fans,
but truly it is for everybody.
It makes you feel so good,
live theater is so good.
So no matter your walk of
life or where you live,
live shows are accessible.
Many Broadway hits like Shucked,
end up touring the country
so you get a chance to see
them if you're not in New York.
So today we are launching a new segment,
which I love, "Broadway and Sixay."
(audience cheering)
♪ Broadway and Sixay ♪
- And I love that it's in your show.
- Me too.
- I love that it's your show.
Y'all have no idea how full
circle this is, it's so cool.
So not only are we giving
viewers an inside look
at some of the theater district's best,
we are also sending a
Broadway newbie to see a show.
So this is Dave.
He is a lifelong New Yorker
and retired tour guide
who never goes to theater.
He just doesn't do that, right?
So what would he think of Shucked?
Well, we sent him to the show
last night to find out, so.
- I'm not exactly a Broadway guy,
but tonight I'm here to see Shucked.
It sounds like a great play.
It's about corn!
How are they gonna get
two hours about corn?
I'm here in the lobby and
they're still coming in.
It looks like a sold out crowd.
It's gonna be great, I am really excited.
Terrific seats, lot of energy.
I'll let you know tomorrow what I think.
- In a few moments, everybody,
the cast will perform a song,
but first let's talk to Dave,
a lifelong New Yorker who
never attends Broadway.
We sent him to see Shucked
for his honest review of the musical.
So you're not usually into
Broadway shows, right?
- Nope.
- You would think as a
lifelong New Yorker I would be,
but I've been a tour
guide for 38 years, just-
- Okay, you were busy.
- Never found the time.
- Yeah, never found the time.
- You were busy, yeah.
I'm a little disappointed, it's fine.
I'm just kidding.
So, so you're, you're ready
to share your thoughts, right?
- Yep.
- Okay.
- I asked about it and I
said two hours of corn.
I mean like get real, but,
but it was delightful.
- Isn't it funny?
- It is, among other things,
it is a really, really great show.
It's the type of show that
everyone is gonna love.
- Okay.
- You need to see it like the
guy back there more than once
because the jokes are a little bit,
you have to wait three or
four seconds to laugh at them.
- He's very witty.
- But that's fine, but that's fine.
What I really loved-
- Was the music.
- The music, how you melted
the music and the dialogue
and comedy together and watching,
you could see that all
the players, the actors
really liked doing it.
They liked each other-
- All enjoyed it.
- And they enjoyed it.
They, they, everyone likes getting paid,
but you could see they
would've done it for free.
(laughter)
They would've done it for free.
That's why you could see they liked it.
- I love you.
- Not getting paid, they
would've done it for free.
- Dave, I swear-
- Because you could see their camaraderie.
- I think he's gonna have to be-
- He's going have to be the regular guy
that goes to see shows.
- Who else is gonna do this for you?
- The guy, the guy that
should have paid you
to be in the cast was Bo.
He got to kiss a beautiful girl.
- Yes.
- Hug her a few times, and
at the end of the week-
- I see where your mind's at.
- They give him a paycheck.
- They do.
- He gets to kiss a beautiful girl.
- Yep.
- And they pay you for this.
- Got paid for it.
- Can I get this job?
- Exactly.
You would be awesome in corn.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, Shucked.
(laughter)
- You would be awesome in corn too.
- You kiss beautiful girls
and they give you money.
- Exactly.
- Here we go.
- I love where your mind's at, Dave.
Okay, well now it's time
to judge for yourself.
Dave, can you take it from here?
- Yep.
We are performing "We Love Jesus."
You're gonna love this.
It's got everything.
Corn, singing, dancing,
comedy, even booze.
- Nice.
- Here's the cast-
- Here's the cast of Shucked.
(laughter)
(cheering)
♪ Here we are at Kelly Clarkson ♪
♪ With our little farm to fable ♪
(rubber chicken squeaking)
♪ Better send a pigeon ♪
♪ Because Cobb county ain't got cable ♪
♪ If we ain't praying,
then we're drinking ♪
♪ If we ain't drinking, then we're dead ♪
♪ So bring a bottle and a Bible ♪
♪ Let this song get in your head ♪
- Come on!
♪ We go to church on Sunday twice ♪
♪ And even on a Wednesday night ♪
♪ So our chances into the
pearly gates are tripled ♪
(singers cheering)
♪ That leaves us five whole days of sin ♪
♪ And all kinds of crazy to get in ♪
♪ Yeah, we love Jesus ♪
♪ But we drink a little ♪
- Woo!
♪ A little too much, a little too often ♪
♪ When we get started,
there's no stopping ♪
♪ When someone busts out
a banjo or a fiddle ♪
♪ We turn water into wine ♪
♪ We turn corn into shine ♪
♪ Yeah, we love Jesus ♪
♪ But we drink a little ♪
♪ We're up with the rooster, man ♪
♪ Got aching backs and calloused hands ♪
♪ With Uncle Sam squeezing every nickel ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, even Saint Peter had his fun ♪
♪ After a long work week is done ♪
♪ Yeah, we love Jesus ♪
♪ But we drink a little ♪
♪ Come on ♪
♪ A little too late, a little too early ♪
♪ You get bored or you get thirsty ♪
♪ Yeah, we got just the
thing to wet your whistle ♪
♪ We turn water into wine ♪
♪ We turn corn into shine ♪
♪ Yeah, we love Jesus ♪
♪ But we drink a little ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Like a little jig ♪
♪ Like a little jug ♪
♪ Like a little kiss and
we like a little hug ♪
♪ We like a little bacon
and we like a little beans ♪
♪ Love a little butt ♪
♪ In some tight blue jeans ♪
♪ We like a little cow,
we like a little cow ♪
♪ We like a little tipping,
we like a little tipping ♪
♪ We like a little skin,
we like a little skin ♪
♪ In our skinny dipping ♪
♪ We like a little shot,
like a little chew ♪
♪ Love a little, and a doodle-doodle-doo ♪
♪ A little too much, a little too often ♪
♪ When we get started,
there's no stopping ♪
♪ When someones busts
out a banjo or a fiddle ♪
♪ We turn water into wine,
we turn corn into shine ♪
♪ Yeah, we love Jesus ♪
♪ We love Jesus, Buddha, Allah, Oprah ♪
♪ Kelly Clarkson, Deepak Chopra ♪
♪ We love Jesus ♪
♪ But we drink a little ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience cheering)